Do you know onimanju?
It is a famous Japanese sweet from Aichi prefecture.
It became a staple food during the war.
Onimanju was named after the demon's weapon with spikes,...
...which resembles diced sweet potatoes.
Here is the way to prepare it.
First, the ingredients are sweet potatoes, sugar, flour and water.
Second, dice the sweet potatoes and soak them in the water for awhile.
Then remove the diced sweet potatoes from the water...
...and mix them with the sugar and leave for 10 minutes.
After 10 minutes, add flour and mix it.
For more moisture, add water little by little.
Steam them for about 15 to 20 minutes.
Ready to serve.
Enjoy the delicious onimanju.
Yummy!